How does one distinguish a statement
coming from oneself rather than from
radiology?
Hey,
I got a good hint about that.
If you're saying something that
almost anyone else could say,
then it's likely to be either
cliched or ideological.
Where is,
if you're speaking from yourself,
then in some sense you're the only
person who could be saying that.
And so what that means in some
sense is that you've taken ideas,
philosophical,
even ideological,
and you've made them personal so that
you're speaking from a position that only
you can speak from.
And then then you have
something original offer.
Um,
in Solzhenitsyn school,
like archipelago,
he talked about,
uh,
like radical communists who were thrown
into the Gulag and they used to play
comrade with them.
It was a game.
And what they would do is bait them
into making continual propagandistic
communists statements.
It was an attempt to try to educate
them out of their possession.
But it's a good,
see if you can predict what someone is
going to say on the basis of their set of
beliefs,
then they're not speaking.
The ideology is speaking.
And if the ideology is speaking,
you don't even have to listen to them.
You could just read about the ideology
and make up your own mind now.
So that's,
that's sort of the,
uh,
what would you call it?
That's the objective view of this.
The subjective view is that statements
come from yourself that come from
yourself.
I think first of all,
frighten you to some degree because you
actually opened yourself up to the world
by saying something genuine,
but they also make you stronger.
They make you feel stronger put
because I think you're confronting your
vulnerability properly.
You know?
Because if I tell you something that I
really don't believe and you criticize,
it's like who cares?
Because I don't really believe
but believe it anyways,
so maybe I have an ideology
that's like a mask or a persona,
which is generally the case personas,
a end concept that means mask.
And it's often the thing that people
confuse with their real identity.
Well,
if I have a persona and
someone criticizes it,
it's like,
well,
you haven't got to the real meat.
But if I say something that I
really believe deeply believe,
and then it gets criticized,
like I've really put myself on the line.
And so people don't do that.
It's kind of frightening,
but it's,
it's still the way to genuine
strength because you need,
and also not just strength,
but also value.
You need to manifest yourself in the
world because you're a unique thing and
people bite need.
What's unique about you?
Everybody else might really need that.
I believe that you don't because each
person has something that's unique to them
to bring into being.
And if they hide that,
they hide their light under a Bushel,
that everyone is poorer for it.
And you do that in part
as Social Nitsa says,
by turning in,
you're turning over your God
given sole to human dogma.
It's a very bad idea.
Very bad idea.